wenn wir die globale erderwärmung nicht
auf maximal zwei grad begrenzen drohen
uns allen katastrophale konsequenzen die
spätere generationen vielleicht mit
ihrem leben bezahlen müssen zunächst
einmal ist es wichtig weniger
klimaschädliches co2 auszustoßen aber
co2 aus der luft zu filtern ist
natürlich auch ein ansatz vor allem dann
wenn das verdammte co2 dann in ein so
traumhaftes endprodukt umgewandelt wird
wie klimaneutraler treibstoff und genau
das soll die neuartige technologie eines
kanadischen unternehmens jetzt leisten
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannendes heinz videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasste
nichts herzlich willkommen klimawandel
ist zum greifen nahe schaut nach draußen
und der jahrhundertsommer wie ihn viele
schon nennen beweist euch das und
achtung ich verwechsle hier nicht klima
und wetter das wetter ist eine folge des
klimas und der klimaerwärmung und das
haben inzwischen auch klimaforscher
festgestellt und klar ist auch die
globale erderwärmung muss auf zwei
besser noch eineinhalb grad celsius
begrenzt werden
doch unsere zukunft sieht derzeit anders
aus wenn wir so weitermachen wie bisher
könnte es schon bald bis zu vier grad
wärmer sein und das mit absolut
katastrophalen folgen wie man sich
vorstellen kann dürren steigende
meeresspiegel und wüsten in regionen in
denen heute noch nahrung angebaut werden
kann
das problem ist einfach es werden
deutlich zu viele fossile brennstoffe
genutzt und co2 kann bis zu tausende von
jahren in der atmosphäre bleiben selbst
wenn wir jetzt sofort die notbremse
ziehen würde wäre es vielleicht auch
schon zu spät und genau deswegen tüfteln
forschungsteams weltweit an den so
genannten negativen emissions-
technologien net bei denen das
klimaschädliche co2 aktiv aus der
atmosphäre entfernt wird so auch die
kanadische firma karben engineering
deren anlage schon seit drei jahren
kohlendioxid einfängt derzeit schafft
sie eine tonne pro tag das ist nicht
ganz einfach das problem der co2 gehalt
in der luft liegt bei 0,04 prozent auch
wenn er sich in den letzten jahren fast
verdoppelt hat doch möglich ist es schon
das zeigt beispielsweise eine testanlage
bei zürich doch die probleme bleiben
haben wir darüber berichtet
denn der filterung prozess ist extrem
teuer und zudem ist das aus der luft
gefiltert treibhausgas ja auch noch ex
unerwünscht also was tun damit außer ist
unterirdisch zu speichern
die idee der kanadier ist fast zu schön
um wahr zu sein sie verwandeln das co2
in etwas wertvolles in einen
klimaneutralen treibstoff nämlich ohne
öl bohrung und bohrplattformen zu der
neuen technologie einer der ceos der
kanadischen firma steve oldham wenn wir
mit dem auto fahren würde dadurch zwar
co2 freigesetzt aber in ihm als co2 der
atmosphäre wird kein neues zugeführt der
ganze prozess ist nicht komplett neu
erfunden sondern wird bereits heute von
ölkonzern genutzt doch so wie es das
kanadische unternehmen umsetzt ist es
neu kombiniert und dadurch optimiert
vereinfacht gesagt funktioniert es so
die luft wird mit hilfe von riesigen
ventilatoren eingefangen und das co2
durch eine hydroxyl lösung absorbiert
diese flüssigkeit wird dann in reines
co2 umgewandelt das zusammen mit
wasserstoff zu benzin oder diesel
verarbeitet werden kann und dass durch
relativ wenig energiezufuhr um das ganze
funktioniert nicht nur in der praxis
sondern wurde auch vom gründer und
gleichzeitig harvard professorin einer
fachzeitschriften detailliert
beschrieben pro tonne gefilterten co2
fallen demnach kosten von knapp 100
dollar an eine super entwicklung denn am
anfang waren es noch keiner dollar
zukünftig könnte eine fabrik im jahr bis
zu einer million tonnen co2 aus der luft
filtern
das entspricht etwa dem jährlichen
ausstoß von 250.000 autos das ganze
könnte echt zukunft haben nicht umsonst
investiert bill gates in die kanadische
firma die übrigens schon bei einem
großen klima wettbewerb ziemlich
erfolgreich abgeschnitten hat die
gründer von kabeln engineering
jedenfalls sind optimistisch dem klima
mit ihrer neuen technologie helfen zu
können
dazu zählt david peace wir sollten als
erstes versuchen den kohlendioxid
ausstoß zu bremsen es ist billiger co2
gar nicht erst raus zu stoßen als es
dann wieder einzusammeln aber wenn wir
das nicht hinkriegen müssen wir über das
großflächige ein fang von co2 nachdenken
er ist übrigens auch ein entwickler der
im bereich geo engineering zahlreiche
indien entwickelt hat beispielsweise
künstliche wolken zu produzieren um die
sonneneinstrahlung zu reduzieren oder
aber die meere mit eisen zu düngen damit
sich algen vermehren die co2 fressen das
konzept seiner kanadischen firma klingt
im vergleich dazu deutlich wahnwitziger
und könnte uns am ende vielleicht doch
noch
renten ob sie wenn er kein video zu
diesem thema in zukunft und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
abonniert kriegst du auch auf englisch
denn auch da gibt es immer wieder
videopremieren dafür einfach hier
klicken und darunter geht es weiter mit
ice age in europe burgau stream komtur
stencil bis bald hoffentlich auch auf
dem englischen kanal zu tun
stay tuned